I think the media the media is the ones
who've done the worst job so far with
the 20/20 election and when I say that
here's what I mean seven eight weeks ago
who was the darling of the media that
would be better or Roarke do you
remember him I know a lot of people have
already said oh my god I thought he had
dropped out better O'Rourke is still
running for president it's just he's not
getting that glorious media coverage
that he was getting any early days he
was going to be the savior of the
Democratic Party right now I guess who
mayor Pete maybe he's the one who's
getting a lot of attention everybody's
focused on him and hammered with him he
speaks a lot of languages he plays
instruments he's a nice sweet guy week
on policy very week on policy probably
doesn't have a big chance of beating
Donald Trump in 2020 but he is the
media's flavor of the month
and next month will probably be a new
one and so on and so forth and so on and
so forth because the media coverage of
2020 is already complete garbage
it's absolutely infuriating but it's not
just their coverage of picking and
choosing which candidate they want to
lift up and you know they also Biden
who's gotten more coverage than all of
the other people running combined it's
the fact that they're burying certain
people Elizabeth Warren only in the last
you know 10 days finally started getting
the media coverage that she deserves I
mean this woman has more plans than all
of the other candidates combined
basically and they always treated her
like an afterthought Kamala Harris
whether you love her or whether you hate
her you got to agree that the media is
doing a really bad job with her in fact
all of the women running for president
seem to get buried by the media so
here's my quick advice don't pay
attention to the horse race find a
candidate whose values and ideals and
plans fit within your values and ideals
and plans and the things you want to see
happen to this country and support them
ignore the media ignore the horse horse
race educate yourself and vote
accordingly
I'm fair and cousins and for David
Pakman we'll be right back